because you say uh japan is so
into a brand and a lifestyle
is it similar than with the celebrities
that
if they see a certain celebrity as part
of this idea
yeah then they follow that yeah
what about reality shows you know here
in the states there's so much
black and white over you know it brings
down
our culture you know it teaches people
that to be antagonistic
but people still want to watch them
advertisers still want to
have their products shown with them what
are your thoughts on that
do you have any reality shows for wow
wow no no no
oh and the network tv doesn't have it
too
and maybe only one for now
that's so different from here so people
doesn't understand why the reality show
doesn't work
in japan and then to be honest with you
i don't
know the reason and
actually i enjoyed one reality show on
the japanese network
but the other network doesn't have it
and then
we don't and that's so different from
america
yeah and that one reality show
what is it based on it's kind of
sharehouse so there's three
female and three male that live together
but they're not the jersey shore maybe
it's so boring to the u.s audience
they just live our life together and
then
sometimes it's girlfriend boyfriend but
they broadcasted maybe over one year
almost two years but only two couples
during the two years
can you believe it the american people
doesn't watch it
and there's no fighting or if it is no
not at all
we love harmony right right yeah
you